[Music]
[Applause]
and the hall of famer dominique wilkins
back on the show nick what did you take
away from last night's hawks performance
against the hornets well i thought our
defense was outstanding last night from
start to finish we really put them in
uncomfortable situations
last night so i thought from a
from a
defensive standpoint we really put our
stamp on that game and it really
generated a lot of easy offense for us
especially in the second half
who does trey young remind you of
you know he he
he's a special young man i mean no he
has a court vision like a feet marriage
who can really
uh get people involved i mean
unbelievable court vision this kid has
and his ability to get to a to b as
quickly as possible you know when either
with the three-point shot or the drive
man so it's hard to say this one guy
remind you but the first guy that comes
to mind is someone like a pete marriage
who
really does a great job at really
getting people involved i mean he's a
wonderful pastor did you face merevitch
no i did i missed marriage by i think
one or two years um but i used to
actually when i was in college i used to
work out with him in the summer so he
helped get me ready for the nba what was
that like
oh it was man it was fun to me here's a
guy
that
i had a lot of respect for and and i
knew of him and i met him a few times in
atlanta and so when i was at georgia he
used to come down you know on the
weekends and we used to work in ball
hammond scale shooting and those sort of
things so we had a really cool
relationship and he was one of the great
ball handlers of all time i know we look
at kyrie now
but marovich and then you realize that
you know that guy was scoring 45 points
a game in college
he was before his time yeah
what he was doing never been done before
and he did it he averaged that in
college 44 points a game which is pretty
amazing when you sit back and think
about it with no three-point line
what would you have been like though in
today's nba
oh man
you know
i come from area where you know it's
physical bump and grind and uh
you can put your hands on people and i
still was averaging
you know 28 29 30 a game
uh
i don't know if i had the freedom of
movement where people couldn't put their
hands on me i don't know but i i i
believe to be a lot more than 35 a game
um
it's because of
the freedom that you have you know so
it's easier to score
did you have a rivalry with jordan when
it came to scoring i know there was this
slam dunk contest but did you feel like
you were
every bit as good if not better than
jordan oh man we had plenty rifles
plenty rival you know michael and all
the guys i played against probably the
most fun guy to play against michael
jordan man because he
raised your level of play intensity wait
fun i've never heard somebody describe
playing against jordan as fun nick it
was it was fun what i mean by that is
that
i was excited to play against him so it
was fun to go against a great player
like of course the competitive level was
a whole different level uh because we
were very competitive we wanted to kick
each other's butt there's no question
about that and so we we have some fears
fierce um
games that we played against throughout
our career um we against one another
in our careers we averaged 30 over 30 a
game against each other in our career
and so when i say fun
that's the atmosphere was that's what
basketball is about to play against
somebody like that i don't remember you
talking when you played
did michael talk
i didn't talk much no
it's certain times that you talk now
mike
might get under your skin you know he
might say a a little bit but he really
he wasn't a big time trash talking he
didn't have to be but
if he talked trash you know he was
trying to get in your head or somebody
he didn't like so but other than that
now he didn't talk a lot
you remember your first playoff game
oh man
my first playoff man
that's so long ago i i can't remember i
believe it was funny against
i don't know milwaukee i think it was
but that's been so long ago and it
caused me to think that far back
who did you
you couldn't wait to face
who which individual defender
man that's a it was a lot of great
defenders back then no no the guy who
wasn't any good like um i asked george
girvin i said ice who was the guy that
you couldn't wait to play against he
goes kevin grievey
kevin grievey
um
oh man that's good because the the guy
that i most wanted to play against but
from
from a defensive standpoint a guy who
i love playing against guys like kelly
chaputa
you know
there was something about him man that i
couldn't wait to play
well yeah didn't he did he have the uh
the fro back then or you know yeah yeah
he did yeah he had the perm or whatever
that yeah yeah
and i remember in a playoff game i i
went for 50 in a playoff game
you know i hope he's there tonight
uh i got your first playoff game
is against boston 1983. it was oh okay
yeah that's a long time ago wow i know
i wouldn't have guessed boston you know
if i didn't go back and look through the
archives but
that was a great boston team
that was that's that's your first time
facing bird
and well in the playoffs yeah yeah cause
you guys had great battles
yeah you know you know that the first
time bird ever talked to ashley it's my
rookie season my first game i ever
played against him what do you say
that was the only thing uh
i can't even tell you what he said
clean
one of the things that the first thing i
think is really the only thing he said
to me i'm guarding him my first play
you know
uh i'm he's coming down the court and
i'm guarding him he looks at me said i
don't know why they have you guard me
holmes and he shoots the three
now
i wasn't upset he made the three i said
but this summer gun just called me home
you know but it was funny because after
that because you know they knew
i was going to keep coming you know but
that was the only time he ever talked to
ask me and then we we we had a lot of
respect for each other over the years
and so i never forget that one thing
though man i'm like i was so hot
[Laughter]
oh man but you know we talk about that
stuff to this day man we need to sit and
laugh about a lot of that stuff well
bird famously wouldn't talk
to i think it's dan marley um he would
talk to maybe alton lister or somebody
and he he said i i i feel so
disrespected that you guys put a white
guy on me
that's larry that slayer
that's
how was the 75th anniversary party
oh man that was
that was amazing it was
it was breathtaking did you meet
somebody that you had never met before
yeah yeah you meet quite a few people
that you've never really had a chance to
talk to um
it was when you walk into that room and
they're taking pictures of you know the
greatest players
man the electricity in the room i mean
the emotions in the room it's hard to
explain
and um it was so many of us that was
just in awe of that moment so that's
something that
is with you for the rest of your life
hawks go to the eastern conference
finals last year how deep can they go
this year
well you know
similar situation of course we were much
better situation last year as far as
being in the playoffs
um
but now you know we still have an
opportunity if we win this next game to
get to the eight spot and have a chance
to play against miami you know and i
think we match up very very well against
them so i i love the hawks chances you
know against a team like miami but hey
we got to get by cleveland yes you do
and that's going to be tough because
although cleveland not having jared
allen but that's that's a good team and
darius garland and trey young will be a
good matchup
oh yeah it'll be a great matchup and and
you're right that team is so big up
front now jared allen plays tomorrow
night
which you know we hear rumors that may
happen you know
they get bigger you know because mobley
just came back so it'll be a tough game
but again you know we go in and cut down
a mistake to take care of the basketball
we have a great chance of winning that
game
can you explain why zion's not playing
well i just heard you say he was in the
layup line uh duncan doing 360. it
seemed like to me you ready to play if
you can do all that stuff but hey
you know
who knows
yeah i just don't understand that you
know if if you've you're not clear to
play are you cleared to do 360s in
warm-up sneak
you know i come from a different era you
know we was like hey if we're healthy
enough to walk up and down the court and
run you can play yeah you know
um
for whatever reason it's not that same
mentality you know i played with
two dislocated fingers and sprung ankle
and the temperature of 103 didn't think
once by not playing because that's how
much i love the game and i felt like
i owe it to my teammates to be there
that was just my mentality if i did an
over 60 slam dunk competition
are you the number one seed
uh
no
no
hey i'm gonna tell you something man
i've seen dr j and i've seen kareem
allen guys dunk over 64. you know when
it was before they were dunking the
basketball i might give you one but you
know the thing is going up is easy
that's what vince carter told me he says
i can go up it's just coming down is
what hurts but he still has an advantage
he's a lot younger than all right so
he's got a major advantage that would be
interesting if dr j
would win the slam dunk contest of the
over 60.
hey look you know it's
quite a few guys who i think could uh
could fit in that category you know that
i look at clyde drexler
yeah you know he's another guy who's
still can throw it down pretty easily
doc is 72.
i didn't know doc was that old yeah you
know he still looks like he said just a
few years back i used to see him and he
told me he said i try to do one dunk a
year every year i try to do a dog you
know and he's and he has it's pretty
amazing
great to talk to you as always nick and
uh good luck with the hawks uh on friday
always good to talk to you dan
appreciate you thank you bud that's uh
domonique wilkins
always good to talk to you human
highlight film one of the great
nicknames there